hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today i'm going to talk about the
turkish language
now right off the bat the first thing i
want to say is that there
is a turkish language because turkey is
situated
at the edge of the middle east some
people think that turkey is an arabic
country
but it is not an arabic country the
language of turkey is turkish
although there is a small
arabic-speaking minority in turkey there
are around 75 million native speakers of
turkish that includes 10 to 15 million
people in southeastern europe that's
mainly in the part of turkey that's
located in europe but also as a minority
language in the balkan area and it
includes 60 to 65 million people in
anatolia that's the part of turkey
that's located inside of asia now those
numbers are for
turkish but there are other languages
inside the turkic
language family that have a relatively
high degree of mutual intelligibility
and some people consider those languages
to be dialects of turkish so if we
include those
the number might be as high as 109
million people but let's back up and
look at the classification of turkish
because turkey is located partly inside
of europe you might have thought that
turkish is an indo-european language or
a slavic language
and because part of turkey is located on
the edge of the middle east you might
have thought that turkish is a semitic
language but it is none of the above the
turkic language family is a separate
family
unto itself the turkic languages are
sometimes thought to be a part of a
larger language family called the altaic
language family which includes some
other language groups like the mongolic
language family the japonic and the
koryanic language family
amongst others but this is not a
generally accepted theory by linguists
it tends to be debated and these days it
seems to be
fairly discredited turkish is part of
the oz branch of the turkic language
family it also includes azerbaijani
which is sometimes called azeri turkish
as well as turkmen as well as some other
languages like kashkai which is spoken
in some parts of iran
the languages of the oz branch are all
mutually intelligible to some extent and
these are the languages that are
sometimes considered to be dialects of
turkish
azeri turkish is spoken in azerbaijan as
well as parts of iran
iraq dagestan and georgia and it has 26
million native speakers
turkmen has 8 million native speakers
including 3.5 million in turkmenistan
2 million in northwestern iran and 1.5
million in northwestern afghanistan
all turkic languages descended from a
theoretical language called
proto-turkish
the turkic peoples originated in central
asia and through migration they expanded
over a wide area extending all the way
from
siberia down through china and central
asia through the middle east
up into the balkan area and even north
of the black sea o's turkic the
ancestral language of modern day turkish
language as well as all the languages of
the oz branch
was brought to anatolia by the seljuk
empire a turkic
empire in the 11th century ce the seljuq
empire had previously adopted islam and
they were admirers of persian culture
and they were influenced by the persian
language and the arabic language
persian became the administrative and
literary language while arabic was used
for religious purposes
but turkish was still spoken by the
average common people
later when the ottoman empire arose in
place of the seljuk empire the official
language would be a form of turkish that
was highly influenced by persian and
arabic
this form of turkish became known as
ottoman turkish
ottoman turkish was based on turkish
grammar but with some influence from
persian and arabic grammar
but it was the vocabulary that was most
influenced by persian and arabic
sometimes up to 88
of the vocabulary used was persian and
arabic this was the language of the
elite people not the language of the
common people which had much less
foreign influence although it did still
have some foreign influence when the
modern republic of turkey was founded in
1923
mustafa kemal ataturk created the
turkish language association to initiate
a reform of the turkish language
he essentially got rid of that
administrative language ottoman turkish
and he replaced it with a new standard
language based on the everyday common
language spoken in istanbul
an effort was made to replace persian
and arabic words with native turkish
words sometimes those were archaic
turkish words that were brought back to
life and sometimes they were
newly created turkish words taken from
turkish roots
another big change is that turkish was
switched from the arabic alphabet the
arabic writing system to a modified
latin alphabet which was much more
suitable for reading and writing turkish
arabic has only three short vowels and
three long vowels while the turkish
language has eight vowels that created a
lot of confusion in reading and writing
in turkish
and the literacy rates had always been
very low but after switching to the
latin alphabet the literacy rate
skyrocketed but the common people
haven't always accepted the suggestions
by the turkish language association so
some of those foreign loan words in
turkish
still exist alongside native turkish
words so sometimes there are two words
for the same thing one turkish and one
persian or arabic and they might have
the same meaning but they're used in a
slightly different way or have a
slightly different sense to the meaning
before i mentioned the azeri language as
well as the turkmen language which are
sometimes considered dialects of turkish
but they are actually more similar to
the turkish that was spoken before
adaturk's reform
of the turkish language that is to say
that they use more persian and arabic
loanwords than the modern day standard
turkish
of turkey uses and also azerbaijan and
turkmenistan were under the control of
the ussr for a long time so there are
also some russian loanwords
and from what i understand there are a
lot of funny misunderstandings between
the different varieties of turkish
azerbaijani or azeri turkish was always
referred to as turkish
until the soviet union controlled
azerbaijan and they
changed the name of that language as a
way of trying to create an identity for
those people that was
separate from the people in turkey that
was another divide and conquer
tactic just from reading some comments
around the internet the level of
intelligibility between standard turkish
and azeri turkish
varies from 60 to 90 but even for the
people who
understand less of it it seems that they
get used to it quite quickly and it's
simply a matter of familiarity and a
little bit of adjustment
for example one guy wrote in his comment
that if a turkish person
takes an airplane to azerbaijan maybe in
the morning he won't really understand
very well but
by the afternoon he'll be completely
fluent and if that is the case then i
would definitely say that those are just
two dialects of the same language so
let's look at some features of the
turkish language
turkish is an agglutinative language
agglutinative means that the words are
comprised of pieces that all
add to the meaning of the word so
whereas in english you might express
something with a few words
in turkish that might just be one word
or it might be fewer words because
instead of using an extra word you just
add an extra piece to the word you're
already using
that means you can sometimes get some
surprisingly long words in turkish
let's look at an example of
agglutination
so you can see that if we add a piece to
the end of the word we're adding to the
meaning of the word
this way of attaching suffixes to the
end of a word is also used to make
plural forms possessive forms and to
show
grammatical case for nouns let's look at
an example for the plural form
let's look at another example with
possession this time
let's look at an example of the
grammatical cases in turkish
there are six grammatical cases in
turkish and again if you don't know what
a grammatical case
is that means that the form of the noun
changes depending on its function in the
sentence
the word we're using is tree arch
arjun
so you can see that the form of that
noun changes depending on what function
it fulfills in that sentence how hard is
turkish to learn
well that depends on your native
language if your native language is an
agglutinative language or if you know
another agglutinative language
then turkish might seem more familiar to
you but if you have never
spoken a language like that before you
might have to get used to a whole new
way of thinking but the good news is
that turkish grammar is very systematic
and very consistent and so is the
writing system turkish is almost
entirely a phonetic language that means
that
for each sound there is one letter so
when you read a word you know how to
pronounce it
and when you know how to say a word you
know how to write it and as always if
you're deeply fascinated with the
culture then it doesn't matter if the
language is challenging because you'll
be motivated enough to
get past those challenges and you'll
enjoy it every step of the way
so if you happen to be very interested
in turkey or in azerbaijan or
turkmenistan or
other places where turkish has spoken
then don't hesitate to start learning
the turkish language
thank you for watching the langfocus
channel what should the question of the
day be i can't
decide between a couple so i'll give you
two choices so people who
speak turkish or have studied turkish do
you think that azeri turkish and turkmen
are
the same language dialects of the same
language how well do you
understand each other and another
question that i'm curious about
turkish people if you try to read
ottoman turkish from that period how
well do you understand it are there too
many loanwords too much persian and
arabic for you to understand or
is it close enough that you can
understand it let us know in the
comments down below everyone else
comment as you wish have a nice day
you